die uhr tickt und die zeit für
opportunity läuft ab seit dem heftigen
staubsturm im sommer 2018 hat die nasa
keinen kontakt mehr zu ihrem mars-rover
alle bisherigen wiederbelebungsversuche
sind gescheitert jetzt startet das nasa
ingenieursteam einen letzten
rettungsversuch wie die chance für
opportunity wirklich stehen und welchen
tricks die nasa jetzt noch auf lager hat
klick zum science fiction hier gibt es
täglich neue faszinierende wissenschafts
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nicht herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
das war wirklich ein drama wochenlang
tobte im sommer 2018 ein heftiger
sandsturm auf dem mars laut nasa ein
planeten umfassendes staub ereignis
mitte juni dann die horrormeldung die
nasa musste mitteilen dass sie den
kontakt zu ihrem rover opportunity
verloren hatte die vermutung der sturm
blockte das sonnenlicht ab dass die
solarzellen von opportunity zur
energiegewinnung benötigen die
akkuladung war letztendlich so weit
gefallen dass sich der rover
selbstständig ihnen einen ruhemodus
versetzt hatte tatsächlich eine
ziemliche tragödie denn der mars rover
ist der dienstälteste und damit
zuverlässigste und fährt seit 15 jahren
über die mars oberfläche und genau
deswegen lässt die nasa seitdem nicht
locker um opportunity doch noch
wiederzubeleben
dazu john callas erst nasa
projektmanager auch wenn wir nichts mehr
von ihnen keine antwort erhalten haben
und die wahrscheinlichkeit dass das noch
mal der fall ist von tag zu tag geringer
wird werden wir weiterhin jede logische
möglichkeit nutzen um wieder kontakt
aufzunehmen mittlerweile sind es laut
nasa mehr als 800 wiederherstellungs
befehle die anrufer gesendet wurden
jetzt startet die nasa einen
allerletzten versuch opportunity wieder
zu reaktivieren konkret werden dazu neue
befehle genutzt die die bislang
eingesetzten kommandos ergänzen mögliche
fehlfunktion sollen dadurch behoben
werden eines der insgesamt drei
kommandos befiehlt dem rover seine bord
uhr neu einzustellen und auf das
ersatzmodell zu wechseln der zweite
befehl bezieht sich auf das zweite der
drei möglichen szenarien nämlich dass
das so genannte ex band also die primäre
funkverbindung nicht mehr funktioniert
das letzte mögliche szenario besteht
daraus dass sowohl das primäre als auch
das sekundäre radio modul ausgefallen
sein könnten
doch läuft der rettungsmannschaft der
nasa die zeit davon das große problem
ist der süd winter auf dem mars der bald
ansteht die damit verbundene kälte und
der frost könnten teile des rovers
zerstören wenn vorher nicht mehr die
elektronik angeworfen werden kann nicht
nur die computersysteme sondern auch die
leitungen und die batterien könnten dann
irreparabel beschädigt werden dazu
steven cue ihre jetzt von der cornell
university
das ende der winter sorgt könnte daher
das ende für den rover bedeuten und
läuft die zeit davon
aktuell spielt der wind auf dem mars der
nasa aber noch in die hände denn im
besten fall könnte diese sogenannte
staub beseitigung jahreszeit dafür
sorgen dass sand und staub von den
solarpanelen des rovers gewählt werden
darauf hatte nicht nur die nasa große
hoffnung gesetzt bislang ist dies jedoch
nicht passiert was dafür spricht dass
die funkstille nicht unbedingt am staub
auf den sonnensegeln und dem
energiemangel begründet ist denkbar ist
zudem nämlich auch dass die funk stelle
an einem ausfall der internen uhr oder
des funksystems liegen könnte dem rover
droht somit im schlimmsten fall dasselbe
schicksal wie dem rover spirit der 2010
auf dem mars eingefroren war doch egal
wie es jetzt mit opportunity weitergeht
er wird eines der erfolgreichsten
projekte der planetenforschung bleiben
denn opportunity ist tatsächlich schon
seit ende 2004 auf dem roten planeten
unterwegs und hat die ziele seiner
entwickler und entwicklerinnen damit
längst übertroffen ursprünglich war
geplant dass er lediglich 90 tage lang
dem planeten erkunden soll interessanter
effekt mittlerweile hat eine 14 jahren
schon rund 25 kilometer zurücklegt mehr
also als die streckenlänge eines
marathons und die fünf spannendsten
fakten über die milchstraße gibt es als
video premiere hier auf dem englischen
klicks und kanal der firefox most
exciting verbaute mitgewählt dafür hier
klicken sehr sehr spannend ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran